still a lot of her mess that pragnanda
needs to clear up here but for example
he can just remove this black knight
from the board if we do a quick count as
well which we should always do when we
come to a new position white is one pawn
up but it's not just the pawn white has
very active pieces especially if we look
on the left side of the wood there we go
he clears things up actually by giving
up a rook for the knight so now it's a
rook for pregnant ladies bishop and two
pawns but more importantly white's
bishop now look at that light squad
bishop just too strong so well
i mean i mean the thing that i i think
was mentioned he had this break didn't
he oh it's over sorry yeah over
it's over pragnanda is the winner of the
match against chocolation and mamadiro
shaking his
hand wow pregnant on that he won his
match yesterday after only three games
and he does the same again jamaica how
impressed are you i'm incredibly
impressed and you could also see from
the footage there that shaq himself was
impressed because he kind of gave
pragnanda